habits allow you to solve the problems  of life with less energy and effort than  you would otherwise need and  you know all life requires energy to  exist if you if you don't have energy  then you don't survive and so energy is  very precious for that reason and your  brain is looking for ways to conserve it  whenever possible um  you know this makes just logical sense  right like if you imagine like our  ancestors living on the savannah if you  could forage for berries in a patch  that's 100 meters away then why would  you bother foraging for berries in a  patch that's like 10 000 meters away or  on the other side of the mountain or  whatever right like you're gonna seek  the path of least resistance to get the  results that you want  and habits are sort of a shortcut a  mental shortcut that your brain uses to  to do that kind of thing on a daily  basis